while editing might sound like the
simplest part of a movies production bad
couldn't be further from the truth it's
not just putting footage in a timeline
it's determining everything about how
that movie will be perceived in the
editing room a movie's entire tone can
change on a whim no big deal right
it's only everything an editor often
working side by side with the director
has the ability to reshape the film as
they see fit however as we all know with
great power comes great responsibility
a maxim the editors of the movies on
this list couldn't live up to here are
the movies that were ruined by really
bad editing Justice League the Justice
League movie didn't swing the DC EU
around much as Warner Brothers had hoped
it would
instead Justice League sank into Rotten
territory on Rotten Tomatoes with
slipshod editing being among critics top
complaints with the film due to Zack
Snyder leaving midway through the film's
development and Joss Whedon taking over
there are two distinct tones in Justice
League
Snyder's grim realism and Whedon's can't
be optimism here's the suite of bugs
guns naturally tall people and burger
iqp
while that's not the easiest issue to
fix in the editing room it is something
the film's final cut should have done a
much better job of rectifying worse yet
the haphazard editing led to important
exposition being cut from the film in
order for the studio to achieve its
desired two-hour run time I honestly
didn't hear anything after we're all
gonna die these are just some of the
biggest reasons fans continued to
petition for a purely Zack Snyder cut of
the film sadly even that rumored version
likely wouldn't be able to remedy
Justice League's largest editing flaw
namely mustachioed Superman the solution
to digitally remove actor Henry cavils
mustache which only existed when he
returned for reshoots was ham-fisted and
blatantly obvious in the final cut
Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice sorry
DC were not done with you yet one of the
most high-profile cases of bad editing
in recent years was Batman vs Superman
dawn of Justice the biggest point of
contention most people had with the film
was its running time clocking in had two
and a half hours long the film was
simultaneously really really long and
way too short how could a film possibly
be both a lot of important exposition
was left on the cutting room floor
leaving audiences feeling the characters
motivations were underdeveloped at the
same time most agreed that the film had
a lot of fat that could have been
trimmed down while Warner Brothers
released an even lengthier director's
cut that did alleviate some of the plot
holes and character motivation issues
found in the theatrical version of the
film the theatrical cut had already left
a negative impression on millions of
viewers
alien covenant misguided editing and
pacing issues squandered the potential
of alien covenant the film inserts
lengthy sequences of exposition
seemingly at random so that scenes built
to provide context ironically end up
further confusing the entire narrative
you were too human too idiosyncratic
thinking for yourself make people
uncomfortable we're still in the movies
horror moments so much unnecessary
foreshadowing was left in that by the
time anything actually scary does crop
up the audience is aware of what's going
to happen three minutes too early right
if I'm the nostrils of all and he'll be
on us for life that you have to get
close transformers age of extinction in
a movie titled transformers a franchise
widely known to be about giant
transforming robots punching each other
there's absolutely no reason for the
majority of screen time to go to a human
cast and their tiny fleshy problems
you'd be forgiven for forgetting that
Optimus Prime is even in transformers
age of extinction the film's editing
completely drops the ball and treats its
robot aliens as a subplot clocking in at
an exhausting 2 hours and 45 minutes
this film chooses to prioritize
downright embarrassing sequences she's a
minor or protected by the Romeo and
Juliet laws we dated for a little while
I was a sophomore and he was a senior
it's fun one can only hope there's an
alternate reality where this movie's
editors decided the heavily advertised
Dinobots received more screen time than
a father and daughter discussing the
suitability of short shorts sweetheart
yes shorts shrinking by the second okay
cold water air dry please the Snowman
the Snowman was a movie caught in an
unfortunate position right out of the
gate since according to director Tomas
Alfredson
he and his production team weren't even
able to shoot the whole thing before
moving into post-production it's
troublesome projects like these where
editing becomes the defining aspect of
the film often becoming the only way to
fix a problem movie especially once the
shooting budget is gone and the crew is
out of time you've probably heard this
phrase before well fix it in post well
we'll fix it in post I'll fix it
if you didn't guess it already the
snowman was not fixed in post beyond
creating tonal inconsistencies
throughout the shoddy cutting openly
exposes the film's nightmarish
production history smashing from shot to
shot so sporadically that one can
practically tell that there wasn't
enough footage to work with Suicide
Squad
sorry DC fans but here we go again
Suicide Squad is the rare example of a
studio publicly advertising a movie is
one thing panicking then completely
reshaping the same film all inside of
one frantic marketing blitz need
evidence
check out the insane differences between
the movies first trailer and second
trailer it's this complete overhaul of
the movies tone that contributed to a
lot of the negative reviews the general
consensus is that in warner brothers
haste to reshape the movie in a more
electric upbeat style to match the
popularity of deadpool they created a
muddled product that's bad on director
david ayers original vision for noir
brothers did more than just confused the
tone of the movie by usurping editing
power from air and his team the execs
also cut out a lot of Jared Leto's Joker
Fantastic Four there's no easy way to
say it Fantastic Four's 2015 iteration
was a failure both critically and
financially while the movie had a lot of
bright spots and sported entertaining
experimental ideas its overall execution
was slaughtered by a plodding editing
that gave the team superpowers over
halfway through the film the
late-bloomer mentality resulted in the
movie having only one major superhero
and supervillain Throwdown in the entire
film if that massive editing faux pas
sounds like a deal breaker to you just
know that the director himself agrees
director Josh Trank badmouth the
studio's cut on Twitter before the movie
had even released in the now deleted
tweet he said a year ago I had a
fantastic version of this and it would
have received great reviews you'll
probably never see it that's reality
though taken three taken three is a
severe case of death by a thousand
cinematic cuts it plays out at the speed
any other movie would run if you
accidentally hit the fast-forward button
several times in a row
if you blink there's a pretty good
chance the film will have already
barreled into another scene entirely
leaving you absolutely lost
unfortunately while some films choose
this speed as part of a broader
stylistic choice take
three uses it because whoever was
responsible for the theatrical cuts
ending just didn't do a very good job at
worst this editing is a recipe for
motion sickness and migraines at best
it's an intensely discombobulating style
of editing that makes it hard to keep
track of virtually any of the on-screen
information star wars attack of the
clones as a wise Jedi once said I hate
bad editing it's coarse and rough and
irritating and it gets everywhere that
wisdom was nowhere to be found during
the editing of Attack of the Clones
the second Star Wars prequel movie while
the movie itself sported plenty of
noteworthy elements like an imaginative
story impressive world design and some
cutting edge special effects the one
thing it's sorely lacked was sharp
editing far too much of Attack of the
Clones two hour and 22 minute runtime
focuses on undercooked romantic and
political subplots side narratives that
could have been cut down without
affecting the film's overall story
whatsoever the quality of the movie
could only have improved if these
lengthy sequences had been cut down to
their essentials giving the happy couple
enough screen time to resonate with
audiences but not so much that they
overstayed their welcome on and Leia
awesome Anakin and Padme who cares
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]